it's not my name or I am the enemy knows
I love God I've exposed the human animal
chimeras I've exposed the surveillance
via the smartphone's I expose the world
government that's unelected I rebooted
with my listeners the entire resistance
worldwide and that's why they hate me
because they track it back to Brazil
they track it back to rocky avec Iceland
they track it back to Eastern Europe
they know that Infowars was ground zero
and like I said that was years ago
I've already metaphysically know that
I've got important work to do as long as
God wants me to but I've already moved
on and it the world's moved on it's not
about me and my temporal power on this
planet I'm a dead man
and like everybody else and I'm just
moving forward and jaian hasn't
eventually gonna die or dead man meaning
your couriers you're done Wood has did
not the enemy wants me dead and I'm
comfortable that so that's it I'm dead
and I'm ready so the work is already
done you figured out like I blew the
blahblah stop it's already happened how
you doing emotionally right now I love
it yeah you've got a poster very close
to God I'm very close to God baseless
you know I think I always felt my heart
stomach knots of my bones like like
every moment is like close to God I
can't explain it I'm so close to God
right now I am are you in prayer mode
right now you are you speaking all the
time not it feel good so you rely on the
piece I am it now I'm now at peace I'm
now at peace it's not my name or Who I
am
the enemy knows I love God twelve Jesus
and so I've already passed on and that's
why the enemy hates me because I'm well
beyond the grasp fell far beyond their
grasp
I just pray that God allowed mercy on my
children but I trust God
so it's God's will now so you don't
think there's anything here for you to
figure out a way to bring you back and
have this be a second coming of Alex's
mind getting to work and doing all that
cept you think it's it for you right now
Oh I mean Lord works in mysterious ways
I'm just telling you that I knew what
trouble is elected election night did I
told her but I said it's gonna get
really bad they're coming after it's
like we've won he'll be the president
we're all set I said no I said no we're
not set get ready and I said I've
completed my work and everything else
now is up to everybody else so I've
already completed the mission and
Trump's trying to complete the mission
and now Trump is giving us prosperity
and everything else and if we don't take
it then that's us see it's a spiritual
choice and so I'm not worried about me I
really am NOT people think oh you're
being a tag being a lot about it like
because we're on target we know the
program and we know better than the
Satanist and because we know the program
they hate us because they don't have the
next level understanding so I'm not
worried I mean there's all these
questions about GMO and vaccines and
globalism and the fertility dropping and
the families and little kids committing
suicide everywhere just evil it's
flooding in and it becomes this thing
about Alex Jones question standing up
he's a bad guy oh my god
you know when they staged all this other
stuff before anybody would question that
babies and incubators you know about
Iraq the babies think you're better it's
1990 and so it's the other day I'm just
not worried like I don't care about the
world I don't care what they say up
honey